- [Announcer:] And blocked by Turner.
That’s his fourth.
- I do my job.
My job’s to go out there and block shots, cause havoc defensively on the floor.
Lay it all out there on the line for my team.
Make plays.
For this season, we have a great team,
and I think we’re gonna make a serious playoff run this year.
You have to have your own mindset,
your own philosophies.
Go back to your training. Remember what got you here.
It doesn’t matter who we play.
Life in the NBA comes with chatter.
Can’t let it rattle you.
If you let your opponent determine
the way you view a game or, like,
your outlook on the game, then that’s an issue.
My future, it’s untapped.
I came to work on myself
and better myself day in and day out.
I watch a lotta film cuz it’s able to show you
every little aspect of one individual play.
I think that’s something that’s gonna really allow me
just to get better and better each and every year.
I came in the league at 19 years old.
This is my fifth year now,
and I haven’t been able to break that first-round ice yet, so,
my expectations are high.
You know, the anchor for, you know, one of the best defensive teams in the league,
I wanna just keep elevating, seek new heights and just make a deep playoff run.
Man, I think we’re really capable.